seit 30 minuten kontrolliert die
bundespolizei die grenze und wie man
sieht hat sich hinter mir schon ein
mehrere kilometer langer stau gebildet
und immer wieder werden pkw
zurückgewiesen leute die eben nicht in
deutschland arbeiten gerade ist sind
zwei männer zurückgewiesen worden die
offen gesagt haben sie wollten bei lidl
einkaufen ihm wurde kurz der pass
abgenommen und dann müssen sie hier
einen kreis bilden und dann umgehend
wieder zurück und dort bekommen sie dann
wieder ihren pass damit man genau sicher
gehen kann dass sie auch wieder zurück
nach frankreich gehen
dank
dann
der situation
branche sprechen sie deutsch
was sagen sie zu der grenzkontrolle wo
möchten sie hin jetzt aber ich müsste
mir in wien wieder gehen
ungefähr zehn kilometer arbeiten ja
arbeiten ja ja ja aber ich bin allein in
der stadt ist es gibt weniger risiko und
ich habe kein fieber
ich habe da ich habe geprüft man die
temperatur gestern abend aber dürfen sie
den rhein nach deutschland war ja ich
muss arbeiten gehen um meine firma
braucht mich sie kommen aus frankreich
sie möchten zurück oder wurst ich komme
gerade hier vorne und dem parkplatz und
will ihnen die stadt einfahren
was sagen sie denn zu den kontrollen
jetzt mach das ja ich hoffe es macht
sinn wenn sie alle daran halte da geht
es ja gut ne rolle als war wichtig nach
soziales kritik
natürlich sei sie möchten ist in vitro
biologie psychologie und sich so sicher
sei
[Musik]